so they relaxed after a while but but
the cast you got along with the cast
yeah they liked you they did you think
probably you always have you always
think about what people think about you
that's what we do i mean that's what i
do i want people to like me
we all do right but did you feel like
the cast likes me they think i'm a
weirdo all the above
i think i understood that they're both
were true i think they i think
they liked me uh i was easy to work with
right um i didn't i didn't come in
screaming you know i didn't didn't have
did you ever get upset did you ever lose
your temper i got upset a lot i didn't
lose my temper
uh i would go back in my trailer and
throw things sometimes you would oh yeah
but i wouldn't i wouldn't so nobody saw
it no no
you'd scream in your trailer you'd have
to you know what you'd have to ask them
you can't recall cause you know you only
remember the things that make you look
good so i
really
i got i'm pretty confident
also in you know i see i see the cast at
conventions or we call each other and
they always reflect back that that was
always really easy to work with and i
like they like me a lot so i think i'm
probably right i you're probably kept
that nice i think it would have come out
by now that you were a real
dick yeah um yeah i also saw that you
know i know that you did a lot of love
scenes or with sarah michelle geller now
she's obviously adorable and she's great
and you're working with her and you're
lonely and you go home was there ever a
time where you're like i've got a little
crush on her i wish she liked me
the opposite
really the opposite yeah so the opposite
yeah like you didn't have a crush on at
all well i had
so spike is alive in me
and spike is in love with buffy right so
that's true
but
for for many seasons we weren't in love
and i came to think of sarah as my kid's
sister who i loved very much
and who drove me crazy sometimes and i
know that i drove her crazy sometimes of
course uh and and we're you know you're
working on a tv show and you're all
nobody gets sleep and you know and so
you see the best and the worst in people
and i and i was like i like my kid's
sister but ah i wish he would be right
right um
uh
and so when they said uh i remember i
went to i went to joss and i was like
look if you ever want me to take my
shirt off can you not mark belucas me
and just give me some give me some lead
time because i can give the difference
between having a body looks good in a
t-shirt and the body that looks good
without one is just a mountain to climb
so just give me a little time to get
ready
and
and he goes oh well i'm glad we're
having the conversation because uh uh
get ready over the summer because next
season you and uh you're gonna fall in
love with buffy
and i was like
great idea dude i've always thought that
that was the answer because the whole
the whole
the whole truth was is like if you're
gonna put spike in the show as a as a
cast member right you gotta you gotta
have him
stop trying to kill buffy in some way
because that was his whole reason for
being
but
if he keeps trying
he either succeeds and we don't have a
show which obviously you're not gonna do
or he keeps failing and that's just
gonna get repetitive and ridiculous and
i always thought
they put a chip in my head which meant
that i couldn't even kill a fly and that
was funny but i thought a better idea
was to have him fall in love with buffy
of course she never reciprocates that
would be ridiculous
but you can see you could you could have
him try to win her love either to and
fail either to horrific effect or
comedic effect and you could run that
one in many different ways and that you
probably could could put together some
seasons on wow and so i just assumed
that was what it was doing and he goes
oh no no she's going to fall for you too
you're going to have sex so get ready i
was like what
i just couldn't see that would have
excited me like i would have been like
oh my gosh that's great i mean as a
professional of course but still
i mean you know
it's you know
you